[ORCHESTRA TUNING]
[APPLAUSE]
[ORCHESTRA PLAYING]
[CHOIR SINGING]
Good evening, ladies
and gentlemen.
I don't remember the exact
year, but in the summer
of the late '90s, I had a
chance meeting with John Oliver
at the time.
I was the pianist for
the young artist chorus.
And John was invited
to do a master
class with our
talented young singers.
Apparently he liked my plan.
And after the class he
asked if I wanted a job,
I said sure, doing what?
He said I needed
a pianist at MIT.
I said great, doing what?
He said while there
are choirs at MIT.
There are choirs at MIT?
And so for the next six years
I served as John's pianist
for the MIT Choirs.
When John retired in 1996,
I applied for the job
and here I am 22 years
later thanks to John.
[APPLAUSE]
John was an incredible mentor
for me during those six years.
And after he gained confidence
in my playing and my abilities,
he eventually hired me to be
his assistant at the Tanglewood
Festival Chorus, the chorus
to the Boston Symphony
which he also conducted.
I spent the next 15 years
having the incredible experience
of working with one
of the finest symphony
choruses in the
country, learning
even more about the
professional world of music
making under the
guidance of John Oliver.
It is because of
these experiences
that I wanted to honor John
with a concert featuring
a work of his choosing.
So that was the original
intention of this program.
When I asked John
what he wanted to hear
he said without hesitation,
I'd love to hear some Dvorak.
And I said terrific.
How about the Te Deum
or the Stabat Mater?
He said no.
I want to hear The
Spectre's Bride.
And I said the who, what?
So here we are performing
this amazing piece
by Dvorak, which he described as
a dramatic musical enchantment.
Sadly, John passed
away last month.
But we decided to go
ahead and still think
of this as a tribute to John
and his incredible musical
contributions to
choral music at MIT.
A proper memorial
concert is being
planned for the fall of 2018.
It seems appropriate
that at this concert
that I present the John
Oliver Choral Award.
This award is normally presented
only at our year end awards
ceremony of Music and
Theater Arts department,
but I decided that this
was really the perfect time
to make sure that that
person was recognized.
Thanks to the generous
donations of choir alums,
this is the fourth
year of the award.
Maestro Oliver requested
that the citation
read in recognition of a
choral student's dedication
to bringing another
aspect of his or her life
to fellow students
to the MIT community
at large through their
dedication to the choral art.
This student should
be a musician
of the highest caliber
with a passion for singing
and a model musical citizen.
I can think of no
one more deserving
than Srini Raghuramam.
Srini is currently a candidate
for the PhD program in Computer
Science with a music mind.
He is president of
the concert choir
and has sung with this
ensemble for five semesters.
He's also sung for
three semesters
with the MIT chamber
chorus, where
he's been a tenor soloist
in Bach's Mass in G Minor.
And most recently Benjamin
Britten's Rejoice in the Land.
This is his first year as
an Emerson vocal scholar,
where he's studying he's
studying a voice with Kerry
Deal.
He's also sung as a
chorister for a production
of Tchaikovsky's opera the Maid
of Orleans with Odyssey opera.
And he's currently a member
of a special collegiate chorus
which will be singing with the
Boston Pops in a few weeks.
Srini is also a gifted
composer and a teacher
of carnatic singing here at MIT.
Besides his many
musical activities,
Srini has managed to help us
organize our recent choral tour
to Spain.
And has been an invaluable
and unofficial assistant
to Kalina Schloneger
in our concerts office.
We literally could not have
done when we did this semester
without Srini.
And especially without his
enthusiastic, always cheerful,
and tireless help.
It gives me great pleasure to
present the 2018 John Oliver
Choral Award to
Srini Raghuraman.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
[ORCHESTRA PLAYING]
[SINGING IN CZECH]
[APPLAUSE]
Everyone, I personally
think this evening would not
be complete if on behalf
of the concert choir
I didn't say a few
words about Bill.
So, there are simply no words
to accurately and adequately
acknowledge and
appreciate Dr. Carter.
Dr. Carter's passion
and dedication to music,
to his peers, and to us,
the MIT concert choir.
Endowed with talent
and humility alike,
Dr. Carter makes for
an exceptional mentor,
both musically and otherwise.
I'm many times dumbstruck
by how Bill somehow manages
to make every rehearsal fun.
With time, I've begun to
understand this better.
For Bill, it's very
much about the music
but it's also about us.
He understands us
and works with us.
And we with him.
We truly are a family.
And this would be
harder to see if Bill
weren't the director he is.
This past semester has been a
different one, a demanding one.
A special one for
many, many reasons.
As we approach the
end of the semester,
I would like to take
this opportunity
to thank Bill on behalf
of the concert choir
for getting us through it
with such strength and grace.
For inspiring us.
For being the Bill
we know and love.
The MIT concert
choir would not be
what it is without you, Bill.
For that and so much more.
We say thank you.
[CHEERING]